wow
we've now recorded more than 100
episodes of the diary of a ceo
and i've had some of the most amazing
inspiring and life-changing
conversations with some of the world's
most accomplished experts business
people psychologists athletes you name
it so this week we're going to do
something a little different
something many of you have requested for
a long time and something i've always
wanted to do
this week we're going to look backwards
this week i'm going to share with you
the key moments the actionable
life-changing epiphany-inducing moments
from the last 100 episodes that had a
lasting impact on me
that changed my life
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
we hear this
phrase
a lot which is find your passion yeah
and i almost feel that it's it's in many
respects quite harmful because it that
question is kind of loaded it it assumes
a singular passion for a star it assumes
that you can discover it like an easter
egg and then and also um the the context
in which that question usually sits in
it implies that once you find it
then it's you know then it's the the the
it's a can of unlimited like happiness
and orientation forever and then that's
yours and it i just feel like sometimes
language can be harmful because it
it simplifies very complex things and
sometimes multifaceted plural things you
know so i wondered if that you know that
phrase uh find your per find your
passion was
something you um you felt similar about
or yeah yeah i do i mean yeah it's true
that passion can be a significant
multiplier of human potential
so you know people are passionate and
engaged in a business they can direct
their energy in a in a worthwhile
meaningful manner so so so it's it's
worthwhile but you're right but um
there's a big difference between passion
big difference between happiness and joy
some are in the moment at home i think
joy is in the moment and i think
happiness is something um that we
continually continually adjust towards
um your passion can be a significant
multiplier of human potential
particularly in the workplace so it does
have a place it is something which is
useful to understand and it ultimately
it always comes down to personal
introspection and self-awareness for me
and i think that um we need to work
harder at understanding ourselves and
when we are constructing a mindset which
is conducive to performance
so we optimize our potential when we're
in a particular state of mind and that
state of mind might be passion it might
be relaxation it might be enthusiasm
might be enjoyment but we need to almost
get to know ourselves and know that um
there are certain things which enable us
to do others and once we work backwards
and understand what that looks like
maybe we can gain some more consistency
i say to a lot of sports people and to a
lot of business people that consistency
of mind gives you consistency of play
and i'm convinced of it and the more
consistent we can be in our thinking
we understand um the building blocks the
component parts to success yeah the more
success we can have
and how does one establish consistency
of thought um because i completely agree
with that i completely agree i've seen
that in my own life when i've been
consistent with my thinking i've managed
to you know perform the same habits
every day um but then sometimes i'll
lose consistency in my thoughts because
i lose um
[Music]
i lose i guess i lose attachment or sort
of my anchor with my my why yeah and i
talk a lot i've talked a lot in this
podcast over the last couple of weeks
about this realization i've had this
year with the gym which was every year
february march i was incredibly
motivated to go
i was fired up trying to look good for
summer yeah and then obviously once you
look good and summer has ended
it's almost like you've lost your
anchor right so like you get into
september and the why which made you go
and to think consistently every day
has been has evaporated and i'm tr i
can't get myself to go to the gym in
october right do you know i mean i
always think that consistency of mind
comes from understanding the intrinsic
quality of our decision-making processes
and i say that a lot to people in sport
and in business so yeah you can make a
good decision and have a really bad
outcome or you can make a bad decision
have a good outcome and this is why i've
worked with leadership teams who have
confused luck for genius made really bad
decisions with a great outcome you know
markets have changed competition's done
something something's just worked in
their favor um so um this is really
important for us to not judge our
decision making by our outcomes
and we often do so we'll say this is a
good decision because it resulted in
this or this is a bad decision it
resulted in that and we can only
understand the outcome retrospectively
so it's wrong to measure our decisions
by the outcomes and we need to go back
to how we made a decision in the first
place and once we start to understand
the intrinsic quality of our decision
making process we can become more
consistent in how we make decisions and
therefore have more control over those
outcomes so i think that you know
two things i think that and then we'll
use you as the example here steve
that consistency of mind will come from
knowing how we make decisions i don't
understand that we put
our weight into evidence how much we use
prejudice and bias and opinion whatever
it might be but let's understand how we
make decisions and in that way we can be
consistent in um how we apply our logic
and thinking and feeling to try and
determine some best outcomes and then
the other thing and um as you've just
positioned is reframing
let's stand back and create some time
and space to understand and um you know
why we do things and why we don't do
things
now i always say that um the people are
most successful and i've had a pleasure
working with six sports people who got
to number one in the world i can
guarantee you one thing i had in common
was that
um they um they never made big changes
and um it was small changes so i'm a big
big believer in the one degree of change
if you take two parallel lines and you
move one by one degree it may not seem
much at first but it's a really big
difference between where you start and
where you end up
so um everyone's trying to you know make
a dramatic change and see change from
tomorrow i'm going to be different i
think it's about doing something a
little bit more than what we've been
doing it ratan a bit more consistently
and then the other thing with these
people who obtained you know what i call
um super achievements at home so they
did really really well um is that they
actually worked on their strengths they
started to understand what was good
about them and do that some more so we
think to be better as human beings i'm
gonna be better as a business or a team
of people we need to fix our weaknesses
um i'm not sure that's true i actually
think it's more about understanding our
strengths and playing to them so
i've actually worked with teams before
in business and in sport who have
actually weakened the strength by trying
to strengthen a weakness
if you think about it it's ridiculous
and actually weaken the strength by
trying to strengthen the weakness we
need to be careful so i think
understanding what's good about us
understanding you know where our
behaviors come from in regard to the
thinking before it and then reframing
some of those words and pictures and i
guess that's what you've done with your
gym example because i guess change some
of the words and pictures in your head
to therefore feel differently which has
resulted you in acting differently yeah
and i really you know i was i was
valuing intensity over consistency and
intensity wasn't sustainable right so i
was going through the summer like to the
gym two times a day i was starving
myself like eating things that i i
didn't want to necessarily eat yeah and
the the consistency came from being a
bit more um realistic with myself being
like you know if you miss the day of gym
it doesn't matter you don't have to
perspective yeah perspective isn't it
yeah and i think do you know it's funny
because again so many sports people have
worked with and business people who will
lose perspective they'll lose the
tournament and it's dreadful you know
win a tournament i've i've made it you
know it's just turning point for me now
they win a big contract you know in
business and you know this is us now
we're set up you know or they lose a
contract and um life has never been so
dreadful
um but i think that we need a better
perspective on things so their ability
to think more long term term to be more
forgiving you know to understand with
more um reality at uh what's good and
what's not so good um it's probably the
way forwards i want to talk about
failure yes now
which seems like a good thing to talk
about and in your book philosophy you
you list
seven
failure principles
number one
failure just is failure is a fact it's
inevitable it's going to happen to all
of us no matter how much we try to avoid
it i guarantee that it will happen and
that can feel scary but it can also feel
liberating because once you've accepted
it as a fact there's no point in trying
to avoid it so you might as well take
the risk
so acceptance of failure starts with the
observation of it
failure is a fact but how you respond to
it is within your control whether you
decide to feel like a failure for many
years after the thing that's happened or
whether you think to yourself okay well
that's taught me something and i'll do
it differently next time
i guess the risk there is
one bad failure people stop trying
exactly and then i i was thinking this
is very similar to confidence in the way
that like if you have one bad failure
your performance next time you get an
opportunity if you actually don't manage
to just avoid it completely will
probably be worse because of nerves and
that you know the memory if i'm terrible
and yeah and then that's going to
increase your chances of failing again
and then the kind of like self negative
reinforcing cycle kind of continues and
you your confidence and your sort of
yeah your guts kind of cascade downwards
and can for some people work in the
other direction where you have a success
your confidence builds you walk on stage
to do that you know public speech next
time around with a bit more confidence
you do a better job which increases your
chance of success and it cascades
upwards
about how failure works from your
experience it can work like that i mean
to take the example you've just given
one of the ways of looking at that if
you're then stuck in a downward cycle
and you're failing and you're trying the
thing is that you're therefore in the
wrong situation so you're in the wrong
workplace for instance that that isn't
generous enough to like
make you feel okay after your failures
or doesn't make you feel like you can be
your true self in which case i would
argue you need to remove yourself from
that situation and find the place that
does suit you
or it can be a question of mindset and a
question of applying that mindset that
we've just talked about which is okay i
failed i'm feeling in a downward spiral
how much of that is fact that's a very
difficult thing to do on your own when
you're a very low ebb and that's why i'm
a huge advocate of therapy and again i
know that i come from a privileged place
where i can afford therapy but even if
it starts with
reaching out to your friend and talking
about it or reaching out to your work
helpline and talking about it or
texting shout the mental health charity
or calling the samaritans that's
a really valuable step
and the other thing that i would say
there is that i'm very aware that my
definition of failure
which is what happens when life doesn't
go according to plan
has a fatal flaw
which is that sometimes there are
failures that are totally cataclysmic
that we couldn't possibly have predicted
that go against any plan whatsoever like
a global pandemic
like
a terrible illness that you contract
like the death of a loved one
it would be monstrous for me to sit here
and say
those failures are as easily assimilated
or learned from or dealt with as fading
or driving tests and so i'm not saying
that at all
those kind of failures will require a
process
of mourning and coming to terms with the
thing that you've lost
and that's absolutely right and as it
should be
my only thing is the way that i choose
to live my life is
i mourn but i don't have to constantly
relive the pain i can still feel sadness
about something but i don't need to live
in that place of reliving it constantly
becoming a victim yeah
and becoming defined by that i can
choose to be defined by something else i
can choose to be defined by my response
to it
i can choose to find some kind of
meaning in something that was
meaningless at the time
and that's how i choose to live my life
because that makes it less sad
and i and i think that that choice is
available for most of us so point number
two in your book is you are not your
anxious brain i think you've talked
about that i met this man called moe
gowda he used to be the chief business
officer of google x but he wasn't happy
and he has a lot to say about
expectation versus reality so if we can
manage our expectations of life so if
they're equal to or less than our
perception of events and how they turn
out then we can be happy or contented
and
he was the one who really brought it
home to me that we are not our worst
thoughts
that our thoughts are produced by our
brain as organic matter in the same way
that blood is pumped around our body by
our heart like
we wouldn't think we were defined by our
blood so why would we think that we are
our thoughts
actually
as you know the premise of all
meditation is that you can observe your
thoughts who's doing the observing
that's you that's you
why would you need thoughts
like
you don't need to communicate yourself
so your thoughts are just being produced
by your brain constantly
and i found that really helpful the idea
that
once you realize that
you can train your brain to think
differently
and to replace negative thoughts with
positive ones as much as you're able so
he gave this incredibly moving example
his son ali died at the age of 21 during
a routine operation
and in the aftermath of ali's death moe
would wake up every morning with tears
streaming down his cheeks and his first
thought would be how he died
and it was
an unbelievably oppressive
grief-stricken thought and after a few
more weeks of it he was like i just
can't live like this i can't live like
this
and so he challenged his brain to come
up with a different thought
and each morning he would wake up and he
would still think ali died and he died
and he'd still be crying but he added
something to that sentence and he added
yes but he also lived
and in that differently expressed
sentiment was 21 years of memories of a
father and son who were best friends and
that was what enabled him to carry on
living and if he can do that in that
situation i sure as hell can do it when
someone criticizes me on instagram
it was a really helpful lesson
almost everyone feels they have failed
in their 20s so i think that a lot of
people struggle in their 20s
particularly in this day and age because
of the curse of comparison and because
we live in a culture of curated
perfection where you're constantly
comparing yourself to your peers
filtered appearance on instagram and the
life that they seem to be living so
we're comparing our insides with
everyone else's projection of their
outside exactly yeah and for many people
although i know not you but for many
people it's the first time that they've
come out of full-time education
and come out of a system of exam and
reward exam and reward and there is no
exam that you can sit to show that
you're being a good grown-up so you feel
quite lost plus piling on top of that
the pressure to find your passion to
like make a career for yourself but also
to earn enough to pay or rent
living in house shares like just trying
to make your way
and trying to forge your identity
in this day and age it's just so hard to
do all that at once and then you're like
oh and i should be having like a
thriving personal life and i should
either be in a long-term relationship or
having one night sounds and making
footloose and fancy-free and drinking
roads and then at the weekend making
vegan brownies because i got to watch
what i eat and all of that sort of stuff
and it's
exhausting and so really what i wanted
to say in that failure principle was
that so many people come on podcast and
say that they feel they failed at their
twenties and i think a lot of us fall
into the trap and i did too of believing
that we had to have our life sorted out
by then and actually your twenties are a
decade of transition of discovering who
you are of grinding up the spices of
life in your pestle and water and the
older you get
my experience has been the more you know
yourself and the more you know what you
want to do and that's where success lies
i've had so many more opportunities
after leaving my 20s behind in the
rearview mirror
wow
when we choose to share our
vulnerabilities is when we feel most
satisfaction
most connection i think is what i said
well i don't why is it so satisfaction
on my own i like that too because you
probably do feel personal satisfaction
it's like but when we choose to be open
about our vulnerabilities that's
paradoxically when we find the most
strength and the source of the most real
connections with other people amen yeah
and that's something that i have
genuinely learned through the podcast
the first season of the podcast i did i
was very much i came from a very
traditional
newspaper journalist background so for
me it was like i'm interviewing
my guest i will ask the questions and i
will listen and then i would ask another
question and it was only as time went on
that i felt more comfortable
sharing my own experiences and whenever
i did that i had such an incredible
like feedback
loop of like just
amazing people sharing their stories and
their vulnerabilities and also saying
that they felt less alone because i
shared mine and really that's what my
entire life is about ultimately
is
connection and so
i really want to encourage people not to
be scared of opening up about the things
that they perceive as their weaknesses
because so often what you think of as
your most personal shame turns out to
have most universal resonance
and that was certainly my experience
talking about fertility and miscarriage
and divorce like actually
that's where i've had
the greatest impact i think and i'm so
grateful for that
why do you think that is why do you
think vulnerable in terms of like why it
has such wide resonance why do you think
that is
because i think that when we're
vulnerable we're being real
and we're letting our masks slip and
you'll see a glimpse of who the
authentic person is and there's
something
just
absolutely quintessentially human about
that so it's a human recognizing another
human
it's a human recognizing another human
beneath the pretense and i think it also
reassures people because as we've been
talking about
in this culture that we live in which is
so defined by social media
and how you appear and the
currency of perfection again it's such a
relief it makes you feel like you can
breathe and someone's like oh god i'll
tell you about today i sat in bed in my
pyjamas eating hummus direct from the
top because i felt really down that's an
act of singular generosity to someone
else who can then have the space to talk
about how they're feeling and that
brings us to the topic of mindset really
nicely you know i've heard you talk
about having a growth mindset and a
fixed mindset what is the difference
between the two
so i think for thank you for what it's
worth i think this contrast is is so
important i mean i can talk about it
through my own life but
you know in a fixed mindset people think
that success however defined is all
about talent
having the gift
having the genetic inheritance and or
you know having the personality trait in
order to excel
a growth mindset is saying okay talent
obviously matters it's a factor
but it's not enough it's what we do with
our talents
so people in a fixed mindset have two
massive risks one they think they're so
talented they don't even need to try so
think of a young person who's just been
um invited to join the manchester united
academy and they're suddenly getting
money into their bank account they're
able to buy the fast car and they think
i'm god's gift and they and the amount
of academy coaches who have come to me
and said we don't understand it we had
this hard-working youngster we invited
them into the academy and then they just
went off the rails it's a fixed mindset
they think their success is assured so
they stop putting in the hardy arts and
don't transition into the first team so
that's one danger the other danger
is
people who don't think that god's gift
but like me at goldman sachs you make
one failure and you interpret that as
meaning i obviously don't have talent
therefore i'm just going to give up
you see what i mean yeah so that's the
negative version yeah so you've got the
i'm super talent is everything
and i've got it so therefore i don't
need to try talent is everything i don't
have it therefore i should give up
they're both terribly
uh damaging i think a growth mindset it
doesn't mean that we think we're all
going to be the best speaker in the
world i wasn't the best table tennis
player in the world i never got into the
top 20 of the world rankings but with
that attitude i maximize my own
potential i'm very intrigued as to um
you know some certain people in our
society
are more self-believing than others um
you see differences in um
genders and races and and backgrounds
and i think a lot of people in my dms
and this is where the question comes
from i have so many young kids in my my
dms that are struggling with
confidence or
lacking self-belief
and i wondered if you had any words of
wisdom for those in my dms that
can't find confidence and self-belief
i
think for what it's worth
um
that self-belief self-esteem
other things are that kind of overrated
um and the reason goes back to something
we said earlier i mean there was a
movement in the 70s and 80s in western
education
to build self-esteem in young people and
the way to do it was to let them succeed
all the time
right so you won't remember this but it
would you give them easy tests
get them to pass
and give them lots of and then praise
them for how super talented they were
they get all this self-esteem and they
can change the world people were so
worried about undermining self-esteem
that there were no losers in sports days
at some schools i don't know have you
heard of this
everyone's a winner yeah ever gets a
sticker you know and that was all about
building it was called the self-esteem
movement right but it failed and the
reason it failed
is because
people would keep succeeding and you
know they'd get all this self-esteem and
then then they'd be given a difficult
test
right or they would leave school and
they'd actually hit the real world where
they would fail and what happened
all the walls of their world would come
crumbling down oh my goodness i've never
felt before right self-esteem that is
frag and people would protect their
self-esteem by not trying new things
right
and and that's a disaster self-esteem
can be very fragile i i like to talk
much more about resilience
we want people we i want my children to
be resilient to try new things to mess
up
but not to be devastated by it
and that i think is a much better quote
now it may be that when people are
talking about confidence what they
really mean is resilience i want to be
able to walk into
to a room give it my best shot things
don't go slightly wrong i'm going to
carry on regardless every person who's a
success
has had some really tough difficult
moments
and i just think that's an inevitable
part of learning how do we build
resilience in ourselves growth mindset
is very strongly related to it so
instead of um you know for parents out
there i don't you probably have a very
young audience i'm so major but but uh
the parents out there it's very easy to
praise young people for their talent
you're super talented they've just drawn
a picture you're super talented you're
the next picasso you think they're going
to develop all this self-esteem
the problem as i've said is that you
know the moment they draw something that
isn't picasso as soon as they get
negative criticism oh my goodness i'm no
picasso after all
um much better thing to do is to praise
them for the effort
or the process well i love the way that
picture that the colors fit together
they think oh right if i want to develop
as a painter i have to make the colors
fit together in a more sophisticated way
you're aligning
their mind and motivation with the
journey they need to take to fulfill
their potential so it's good experiments
praising for effort praising for process
is a much more um positive thing than
praising for talent and fixed attributes
it's interesting because in my company i
came to learn that um the most effective
way to get my teams to innovate was to
praise them for the effort and the
process as opposed to the outcome
because if it became about the outcome
the successful failure of the experiment
then um which is largely actually
outside of their control right when
you're doing so if i say to my team
right we're going to build this website
and we think it's going to do this
whether it does that or not whether
there's product market fit whether it's
a success or a failure isn't actually in
their control the bit they can control
is starting doing it and the process of
getting to the point where we press go
live
and so we what i learned in the last
year of my business was we would
celebrate the um conducting the
experiment not the outcome of the
experiment
exactly right actually that is exactly
the same thing and it's interesting that
if you look at r d you know um have you
had a six sigma yes yeah so one of the
things i mean one of the big master i
mean six sigma is a great process you
know like lean manufacturing or
um
your toyota pro things of that kind it's
basically squeezing out variation
isn't it
so if you imagine making a car
or you know manufacturing car all it
takes is one component in the engine to
be of the wrong size or specification
and the whole thing won't work so six
sigma is about delivering and executing
with no variation
but when you're innovating you need
variation you need to try new things if
you're trying to create a new computer
program a new website or a new drug and
you don't know which combination of
ingredients they're going to create you
need to try lots of combinations if you
penalize people for failure oh my god
and you're only judging them on the
outcome
and it fails and then they're like
stigmatized they will never try
you need you know that's where failed
fast cars
yeah you've nailed it that's exactly the
insight that i think is is important for
some people that's terrifying yeah the
thought of like
throwing themselves into that place of
uncertainty that they have to travel
through before they get to their new
self how do you get someone to come
willingly into uncertainty to leave that
job or to you know take on that
promotion or to
pivot in their career when they're
scared of
the unknown or you know it's like well
then i would think about what i would
think about rather than what i'm afraid
of i'm thinking about what i'm excited
about
and so rather than i'm afraid of what
i'm going to leave behind or i'm afraid
of what might happen i'm expecting more
about
what could happen and when we focus on
what we want and what we could have and
you know it's it's optimism isn't it
it's about what's possible
and what could i achieve you know and
you asked me earlier about you know some
of the things about sports psychology
and visualization was one was a massive
technique really that i learned from my
sports psychologist and employed and
still use all the time and i think when
you can start to visualize
what that new role person
identity could be
and when you bring it to life with all
of your senses
and see it really vividly then that's
exciting
and what what could i achieve and what
could this look like
and
and the power of visualization is that
your mind
does when it's when you see it really
vividly your mind doesn't know the
difference between a vividly imagined
experience and a real life experience
what's your process for visualization
and now is it something that you do
actively you set time aside and do it or
is it just something that you
naturally now do
when you're
pursuing a goal so a little bit of both
as an athlete it was definitely
something that i would sit down usually
i'd be lying on my bed i would have done
some relaxation because the more we
clear our mind and relax the easier it
is to visualize and to see really
clearly and so i would it would be a
conscious right i'm going to spend the
next 15 minutes or even two minutes or
five minutes or whatever time i had
visualizing my next race and seeing
myself execute that race plan as
perfectly as i can and in exactly the
right way and i would visualize
everything from um
if it was
the olympic discipline and we've got
nine boats on a start line i'm seeing my
i don't know which lane i'm gonna be in
when it comes to race day so i'm seeing
myself racing every lane i'm seeing
myself with with the headwind with a
tailwind with it raining i'm seeing
myself [ __ ] up the start because that
might happen but then i just going to
recover from it and i'm going to see
myself recover and i'm going to see
myself win from behind i'm going to see
myself win from the front i'm going to
see
imagine
you know they'll start being delayed or
it's a full start you know all these
eventualities
so that when it comes to the event
i'm prepared
and it can just all unfold and i'm not
phased by anything that happens but but
most importantly i've seen it happen the
way i want it to happen and then i
believe that it can happen and what
visualization also does is when we when
we're visualizing a goal for example it
starts to activate the subconscious
to generate creative ideas about how we
can achieve our goal
it's it's it's my i don't know how it
works and why it works but it's
mind-blowing and it does work and it
starts to um
get your brain to perceive and recognize
the different um
resources that you need
to achieve your goal it's like the law
of attraction and it starts to activate
that in your life and bring in the
people the resources the environment the
circumstances that you need to achieve
your goal and so
now
what do i do i probably i do spend some
time
consciously going right i'm just going
to spend two or three minutes
visualizing my goal i'm seeing it happen
i'm seeing it realize
um but then other times i'm probably
just you know driving in my car and
subconsciously you know like daydreaming
almost but i think the the conscious
right i'm gonna visualize now
is really powerful
because then you start to
really it starts to ingrain in the
subconscious
quick one i talk to you guys about huel
a lot so i'm going to do a quick
intermission to tell you about a bit of
a change that's happened in the last two
months in my life as you guys know my
favorite heel product historically has
been the ready to drink which is these
bottles here they are nutritionally
complete however recently since huel
introduced the heel protein
this now plays a huge role in my diet
the salted caramel flavor protein from
huel which is only 105 calories and has
26 vitamins and minerals and 20 grams of
protein
um serves two rolls in my life now first
thing i do when i wake up in the morning
is i have a glass and then at night time
after i've been to the gym straight
after the gym i have a glass it tastes
amazing if you're going to try it follow
my instructions here
get a couple of cubes of ice put it in a
blender put on the salted caramel
protein and it tastes like a delicious
smoothie i've already gone through one
tub of this i'm actually on my second
tub and i've got two more tubs to go
before i'm gonna reorder more but
genuinely the salted caramel flavor
maybe because i have a liking for salted
caramel for me has been a game changer
professor steve peters steve's invented
this groundbreaking concept called the
chimp model and it focuses on how
there's these kind of three parts to our
brain the first part is called the chimp
which is our sort of desire to be
impulsive and irrational and emotional
and short term the second part is what
he calls the human and you'll hear him
talk about this which is logical and
rational and thinks in terms of facts
and thinks things through in the long
term and the third part is what he calls
the computer which is our set of core
values and beliefs i wanted to talk
about exactly that topic which is like
managing your emotional reactions
um across different facets of life and i
think
um
i'll go let me just give you an example
of a situation that i went through that
i've read about in my book so
i'm just going to be completely honest
because that's what i tend to do on this
podcast um i broke up with a girl and um
like two days later i found out that
she'd slept with somebody else and when
i even though i'd broken up with her
when i when i read the message that
she'd slept with somebody else
my brain yeah
revenge
message her to destroy her life
that's what my brain said to me but i
um and and i'm at a place in my life
where i feel quite
secure in my self-image let's say i
don't feel particularly insecure i'm i'm
i'm a confident person but even i
couldn't seem to get a grip of my own
desire to react emotionally in that
situation
um and really interestingly as well it
was actually my friend calling me i went
to the gym i thought maybe i'll go to
the gym and that'll like clear my head
it was my friend calling me and this i
don't know where this fits in psychiatry
but my friend said to me steve just
remember
you broke up with her she's probably
doing this to um make herself feel
better and to you know rebound or
whatever but um that was one of those
key moments where i was like god like
the damage you can do if you don't know
how to control that like primitive urge
to just bruh
okay you've covered a lot of ground yeah
that could be an hour's work here so i'm
going to take it back and try and go
very steadily to try and drive home
there's a lot of areas one is first of
all what would you expect somebody's
mind to do
confronted with the same situation what
would you expect them to do
probably the same exactly so nothing
abnormal happened there wasn't a problem
yeah you're saying this is absolutely
healthy
and normal but maybe not helpful yeah
and what you really said because you've
told me this if it wasn't a problem to
you you wouldn't have mentioned it so
clearly your human brain is saying i
don't want to get revenge that's not
what i want what i want
is to just be calm and collected accept
the reality of it and move on
unfortunately we have to learn now how
the mind works
so it's like saying you went to the gym
so therefore you're a fitness man if i
said to you right i've never been to a
gym for 30 years i'm going to go tonight
and at the end of the day i'm going to
be super fit
and you laugh because you know that's
ridiculous it's not the way the body
works so we have to now look at another
aspect so now we know it's normal how
does the mind work when we get a really
nasty shock and something which is
devastating so the
the reason that chimp is there and the
reason we're here
is for us to be safe and present the
next generation to the world that's what
the chimps agenda is so what happened
there is the generation that you thought
you were going to get was taken away
from you so this is devastating so we
expect you to be devastated
we also expect you to accept the mind is
going to now grieve and it will take
approximately three months give or take
you're talking about heartbreak here
yeah you've got to grieve yeah so the
mind has a rule on the way it deals and
processes grief i can't speed that up
so if some like if i meet you that night
and i say right i'm going to get you out
of it i'm going to fail because you have
to go through these ripples and and work
it through so your human brain can do it
in seconds because that's logic she's
gone she was dishonest it's a good thing
she's gone now no more wasted time yep
that's easy but our the emotional chimp
brain has got to process it it cannot do
it overnight so you've got to now allow
around a 12-week process and you're
going to go through various stages
of grief in the loss of what is a very
significant relationship and on top of
that there was another insult it wasn't
just she said it's not for me she slept
with someone else so that is really
going to get your chimp you know we
expect it now to be devastated and your
chimps reaction some people wouldn't
but it's common that it wants revenge
it wants to say right if you did this to
me you're going to suffer now
in reality what you've just said by your
nodding is that's not what i want i just
want to move on and accept it wasn't for
me she did what she did that's her
problem not yours
and what your friend did is start to try
and turn it round with some facts to
calm your chimp down and say because it
always looks to the computer let's look
at reality and the reality is if i said
to you
um this girl is going to come back into
your life and they'll bring all that
pleasure you used to have but she's
going to have affairs every few weeks is
that what you want no no see you did
break it up
you know so you just try and look at it
in a different way and say let's look at
the reality and the facts of the
situation but you cannot stop the
grieving you can't stop the yearning or
the bargaining because guys in the
opposition often go back and plead and
then she'll say i made a mistake and and
then you have to make a decision
you know and then they'll bargain again
and then if you go through that you're
going to disorganize stage
but this can all be circumvented if you
suddenly met somebody new your chimp
might recover very quickly is that what
tends to happen well unless we know this
is the rebound right so this is never a
good thing okay i'm sure some of you
listen to going i have married the
person i met on a rebound so of course
it's all probabilities but generally
speaking you need time to get over this
gather yourself so you're in a good
place when you do meet somebody else to
have a good relationship
that's interesting so it's quite complex
the whole thing so yes rationally we can
pull you along but we've got to give you
a lot of tlc and that should go through
grieving don't be harsh on yourself and
what your experiences are totally
natural unhelpful but natural so many
people are going through a grieving
process in it could be a significant
life event it could be the loss of a
partner at the death order is there
anything in psychiatry from your
experience that can
okay that process is unavoidable but is
there anything that i can do to help
that process be easier
yes there is i mean one is understanding
it as you say if you start to go through
this and say to people like this is how
your mind has to do this
and like you tell me in the gym you
laugh i can't do it in the night well
how long and you still it's a bit of a
piece of string but roughly speaking if
you keep going regularly two three times
a week maybe three months six months
you're going to see a difference for
sure and it's the same with me
explaining the mind i would explain to
people that we go through a grieving
process you are likely to experience the
following emotions or stages in the
grief process but you are unique and
everybody grieves individually so it's
very important as i said earlier i don't
have a process uh you know like a recipe
and say this is what we're going to do i
work with you as you grieve but i want
you to get insights that's the key so
the work i do is giving understanding
and insight and then applying this so
you learn the skill of managing your
emotions and the skill of understanding
the skill of mind management that's what
i'm about teaching a skill base so you
can be independent of me but use me as a
fallback
on that on the point of rejection which
we talked about a second ago is it the
stories that i then tell myself about
myself which impact my self-image that
really hold that hurt me the most
because it feels like when you go
through emotional sorry romantic
rejection or heartbreak it feels like
um even if you it it's not the sort of
like front of your mind
the fact that someone didn't want you or
they were they wanted someone else
makes yourself tell yourself that you
are not good enough not pretty enough
not smart enough you weren't enough and
it feels like so much of the hurt and
the pain
lives inside that story you're telling
yourself about yourself and again if you
stop and we'd look at what you've said
there
are these factual statements or are
there impressions and feelings
impressions and feelings so we know that
the chimp brain is in full flow now yeah
so what we're saying is don't quench
that it's not wrong
it's expressing and it's like as i said
you've got this best friend so if this
happens to me i now said what is it
you're telling me and you'll go through
all this you know it's the end of the
world and you know clearly no one's ever
going to love you and and then we sort
of counter it by saying well let's look
at that so we start to rationalize and
that can help the grieving process
because we start saying well let's not
just sit there with these falsehoods
let's challenge them and let's replace
them with truths not brainwash it's no
good saying for example say i'm your
best mate and you've just fallen apart
and you say it's because i'm ugly it's
no good me said no you're really
handsome that's not
that's an impression again from me what
i'd be saying is let's look at facts if
we look at people in relationships do
people find a partner eventually and the
answer is most people yes so the chances
are very high and if you can get through
this
will you eventually get back on your
feet is there a future
yeah yeah there always is a future there
always is a future even for people in a
much more serious situation where they
become
suicidal and obviously as part of my
work
you can tell them with honesty there is
always a future and things do change and
feelings do move
so when you start giving these facts and
rationalizing the facts of the situation
that is going to be powerful for
starting to settle your emotions
but giving falsehoods
you know i know you can do it or you're
that's not going to set your trip
there's street wise yeah yeah so you'll
just keep agitating whereas if we talk
facts
then it'll settle but again there's a
key point here
we have to find the facts that resonate
with you as facts
because if i said like i just did will
you find another partner what's what's
the general rule if you said to me yeah
but i don't believe that everybody does
there's no point me forcing this truth
on to you i'd have to look for others
that might resonate with you yeah such
as if i go out and actually start
socializing when i'm ready then the
chances are i'll increase my probability
so that gives me a bit of hope you might
work with that yeah
so you've got to find what resonates
with the person
and again that's why i don't have this
recipe i'm saying discover them but
think around but you can offer common
things yeah
super interesting and it again it
perfectly explains why in that moment
for some bizarre reason my friend
telling me being very sort of rational
with me things that i genuinely did
accept to be true
just completely diffused my brain
because he's acting effective as you're
human yeah that's what he's doing he's
coming in rationally and stepping back
and saying let's look at the facts here
yeah and he's hit some nails on the head
where you think oh that's settled me
down a bit yeah so but what tends to
happen is
you tend to isolate yourself most people
do this after this has happened and they
go within themselves and they engage
these emotions which generates more and
more falsehoods and distorted ways of
perceiving themselves and the world
instead of being able to which is not
easy talk to themselves rationally
and preempting things like you know
let's work with reality it's not easy to
do that so when you can't do it it's not
a failure you turn to your best friends
and they'll do it for you
so what is the cause of unhappiness as
you see it especially if you're building
sort of machine learning applications
that are gonna
you know
um solve you know make people arrive at
contentment or happiness in a
personalized way we must be able to know
what's causing this lack of
allow me a bit of time to explain it
because it it's simple when we get it
but it's not simple to get to it so so
happiness is very predictable okay if
you look back at any point in your life
where you ever felt happy there is one
commonality across all of those moments
that can actually be documented in a
mathematical equation okay
you've never felt happy
because of a specific event in your life
okay
take for example rain
rain doesn't make you happy or unhappy
there is no inherent value of happiness
in rain okay
rain makes you happy when you want to
alter your plants and it makes you
unhappy when you want to sunbathe right
and so it's not just the event rain it's
the comparison between the event
and an expectation in your mind of how
life should be okay if you're worried
about your plans then life should be
generous to me and get me rain so i can
water the plants and if life does that
then life meets your expectations and
you're happy okay and so happiness in
that sense becomes equal to or greater
than so it's really mathematics that
your perception of the events of your
life minus your expectations of how life
should be
okay and apply that to anything apply
that to anything so you know my favorite
example is nature
we're all happy in nature why are we all
happy in nature i mean you go out there
and there are ants and there are flies
and you know trees are crooked and there
are you know shrubs everywhere and
bushes and it's just really not that
hedged and organized but that's what we
expect
so you know nature's
chaos is what we expect nature to be and
so we feel happy you know nobody ever
sits in front of the ocean and says i
like the view but please mute the sound
okay you just take it you know it's it's
the monotonous sound and the view and
the wind and and the sun and the whole
experience right
and because of that
uh happiness becomes
very different than what was defined to
us okay what was defined to us is that
happiness is found in
a
gathering at the pub or a party or a you
know an activity or some kind of
pleasure or fun or elation or whatever
that is that's not at all true these are
i call these the state of escape okay
happiness as per the definition of the
happiness equation is events equal to or
beating expectations life going my way
okay and so basically happiness is that
calm and peacefulness you feel
when you're okay with life as it is
it doesn't really matter what life is
okay what matters is that you can be
okay with it
right so so you take you know
any example if your boss is annoying
and your expectation is yeah bosses are
annoying this is what life is about they
become bosses because they're annoying
right and and so if if that's your
expectation you're going to look at it
and go like yeah i need to learn the
skill of managing annoying bosses okay
and if that's the case then you're not
going to be upset about it
similarly anything else if you look at
it then it's not just the event
it's your perception of the event so you
have a uh something to influence it's
not just the event your partner might
say something hurtful on friday at 4 p.m
that's the event my partner said
something hurtful at sunday morning you
tell yourself he or she doesn't love me
anymore okay that's your perception of
the event that's not actually the event
the event is something hurtful was said
but your perception of the event is your
work is your it's your brain adding
color to it and then you compare that to
your expectations right you compared my
boss is annoying too my boss shouldn't
be annoying where did you get that from
right so we blur the happiness equation
we break the happiness equation because
of what i call the six and seven
okay six grand illusions and seven blind
spots
which are the six grand illusions are
basically
uh call them pathways
that the modern world teaches us to
navigate the modern world that our
illusions are not true okay
take for example control
everyone knows that to succeed in the
modern world you have to learn to
control certain events right
so you start to believe that the way to
succeed in life is to control everything
but the truth is even if you go down to
the basics of physics that we never are
in control
that the absolute design
of nature itself of the universe itself
is entropy and chaos right that's the
actual design and so if you try to
control it you're bound to be
disappointed a lot of events are gonna
miss your expectations okay and yes i'm
not saying don't control anything at all
but start to understand that you're
you're going to be selective because you
have a finite amount of effort and by
the way even if you're selective and you
you try to control everything sometimes
things will fall out of control if you
live your life through the illusion of
control
good luck finding happiness so six grand
illusions the illusion of uh of thought
the erosion or the illusion of self the
illusion of uh knowledge the illusion of
time control and fear okay now that's
one side and that disrupts your your
entire view of what to expect from life
because you're expecting
life to behave through a length of a
lens of an illusion the other side of it
is what i call seven blind spots okay
and the seven blind spots are not
really defects in your brain as a matter
of fact they are the very design of your
brain okay your brain is designed to
tell you what's wrong
okay it's not designed to you know if a
tiger shows up right here now
my brain has no
use whatsoever in telling me oh my god
look how majestic that animal is right
yeah it's a beautiful animal but my
brain will say we're gonna die okay and
we're gonna die is the idea that
basically makes our
uh our brain constantly look for what's
wrong blur the events of life you ask a
mother
and and she will say oh my daughter's
been sick all winter you know she just
had two episodes of flu three days each
but to the to the caring heart of a
mother that needs to be exaggerated to
the exaggeration is one of the blind
spots
your brain is trying to get you to take
action so it pushes you
it pushes you by exaggerating the event
a little bit so that you jump in and
take action and accordingly the event
you're comparing to you're comparing the
wrong event to the wrong expectation and
the happiness equation falls apart
under all of this you're inferring
something which i think will annoy a lot
of people and that is that happiness is
a choice
and that you you can choose to be happy
and that if you're unhappy and really
for many circumstances in our life day
to day and work and love in
relationships
personal responsibility is the
is the answer and entirely on you and a
lack thereof is the cause absolutely you
know what you just did you've just lost
us 88 of the audience to tell someone
uh it's your responsibility to get
yourself out of this horrible place that
you're in
is quite disturbing because we like the
idea of saying no no hold on no no it's
not me
life is treating me really badly that's
why i'm not happy okay i can't do
anything about it life took my son you
know life took my son i have the right
to be unhappy yes life took your son
that's true and you have the right to be
unhappy but you're never going to get
out of unhappiness if you wait for life
to bring him back or you wait for life
to correct its action okay the only way
you can come out of unhappiness is if
you choose
and say okay it's going to be a long
journey it's gonna take a lot of time
okay and i'm gonna try and try and try
but i'll get there
and neuroplasticity proves that
neuroplasticity basically tells you that
if you just
run a happiness kind of activity once a
day every day your brain will be better
at it
and i mean please don't get me wrong but
what do most of us do every day we watch
negative news we swipe on toxic
positivity and we're just drowning
ourselves in negativity and then what
happens
what happens is we become really good at
being negative we become really good at
finding what's wrong with life become
very good at you know getting pissed off
with the prime minister right because
it's an activity we do on daily basis so
your brain goes like this must be
important for her or him okay i'm just
going to make sure i have the neurons
aligned around that and so you're
basically we're basically configuring
our brains to be unhappy and and that is
the kind of neuroplasticity that we need
to shift
you know if you if you go to the gym
and
lift weights every day you're going to
look like a triangle if you squat every
day you're going to look like a pair
okay the same is happening inside your
brain you just don't see it if you're
constantly watching you know news media
right
you're literally building your muscles
that are concerned and are
you know
critical and are worried about the world
when in reality most of the time you
can't do anything about it
there's something in there which is
clearly a theme in i think three topics
we've touched on which is this theme of
like radical acceptance oh absolutely i
mean this is what i call the jedi master
level of happiness so there are three
levels of happiness right i call it the
happiness flow chart
events are going to piss you off it's
just the truth
if you can manage to acknowledge your
emotion and say oh my god i feel so am i
angry is this anger i mean this is this
what i'm feeling and then and then you
take that feeling and you say to
yourself okay interesting
i am angry i need to do something about
it i will give you three steps okay the
beginner's level is
ask yourself if what you're thinking is
true
your partner said something hurtful on
friday your thought is he or she doesn't
love me anymore okay ask yourself if
that thought is true if it isn't drop it
there is no point to be unhappy if it is
then let's go to the black belt level of
unhappiness which is can i do think
something about it
that's the second question is it true is
question one can i do something about it
this question two right and oh honestly
by the way it doesn't take more than two
seconds
to feel the emotion ask yourself if it's
true and then go to say to to uh to can
i do something about it and if yes then
do it what are you waiting for text him
or text her and say baby can we please
talk over dinner what you said on friday
hurt me
okay instead of just banging your head
against the table hoping that they will
find out and come and say oh i'm so
sorry you know i i i was teaching this
this story really hurts me i i was
teaching you know when before lockdown i
i taught a lot of people in workshops
and seminars more than 20 000 people one
one day one of them comes to me in the
first break and says what are you
talking about what do you mean happiness
is a choice you have no idea what
happened to me
okay and i said okay and she said when i
was 17.
she was 74 at the time
can you believe that
57 years of holding on to one thought
hitting her head against the wall
right and i hugged her i hugged her i
cried and i said did it work
did all of that work
or was the better thought
okay it was horrible
but can i do something about it okay and
that's question number two
that's black belt sometimes however
there's nothing you can do about it
whatever she experienced could be
irreversible what i have experienced the
loss of ali is irreversible there is
nothing you can do about it okay and i'm
not asking everyone to get there quickly
but the jedi master level of happiness
is to say okay
it happened and i have no choice to
change it there is nothing i can do to
fix it so can i accept it
but not surrender and lie down and you
know and die accept it and then start to
do something to make my my life better
despite its presence or maybe because of
its presence okay can i accept that ali
died and start to spread his message so
that my life and the life of others
become better can i do that i call that
committed acceptance okay and it's very
simple if you commit and accept to if
you accept things you you can't change
and commit to make your life better
despite of or because of their presence
nothing can beat you
nothing can beat you and yeah does it is
it horrible that i actually managed to
move on and and you know
not hit my head against the wall for 27
years
does that say i don't love ali what are
you talking about i do rally i cry about
missing him
still today right
it's not that it's there is nothing to
prove in that what what i can prove is i
love him so much
that i actually dedicate my life to
spreading his message that's so much
better
than sitting there and saying ah life
hit me i don't like life right
that's a six-year-old attitude honestly
okay
adults will say okay
and especially business people i mean
your audiences huh
the market changes all the time do you
sit down and go like i lost another deal
or do you just get up and say
why did we lose this deal what can we do
about it
right and if if there is something wrong
with the product can we change the
product
right
well you talked to there about business
in particular rings very very true
because in business and you've been you
know very successful entrepreneur
yourself and worked with teams you'll
get people who are
high in defaulting to logic in moments
of chaos and also default to personal
responsibility and those that don't yeah
and the outcomes of both groups are
quite predictable
very different and actually this this
approach of is it true
uh can i do something about it can i
accept it and and
commit
i learned that in business and it's a
very simple business approach now most
of us do that in business
but when it comes to our personal life
we don't do that
and interestingly
most of us by the way who do that in
business are very successful in business
and most of us who do that in life are
very successful in life
it's not just happy it makes us makes us
successful because it doesn't waste our
cycles on things that are not necessary
so if you can do it at work do it at
home do it in your life do it in your
relationships it's really a very
straightforward flow chart
i hope you enjoyed that look back at my
uh life-changing moments from my first
100 episodes i've got to say november
december january we're publishing
the best podcast we've ever published
when i saw the guest lineup i genuinely
was like i looked at the list and
thought
how how is it possible that my idols
world exclusives people i've wanted on
this podcast since it began many years
ago have all decided to come in the same
month and honestly november and i guess
we're recording with within that month
which will be published over the next
three months is the reason i started
this podcast and it's a real sign of
where it's going and the platform it's
become so
thank you for sticking with me it's
going to be one hell of a last quarter i
know that's going to change my life for
good that's for sure
and i can't wait to bring you more
people's diaries have a wonderful week
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast one of the
brands that make that transition much
much easier they are at the forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology
and their products are really really
changing the game if you're on youtube
you can see what i'm holding in my hand
this is called the eddie right it's the
uk's number one solar powered diverter
so what is a solar diverter it's a
device for people like you and me that
means you can divert your excess energy
back into your home rather than back
into the grid which will save you power
and money it's super user-friendly and
easy to install and you can control it
using the my energy app on your phone to
find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game-changer product and
one that i'm going to be installing in
my home soon
[Music]